he is a consummate narcissist and he
constantly engages in Reckless conduct
that that puts his political followers
at risk and and the conservative and
Republican agenda at risk blistering
words there from Bill Barr but let's put
it all into perspective Barr was also
critical of Donald Trump when it came to
January 6 then the allegations of voter
fraud in the 2020 election he famously
would not go along with the plan to try
to overturn the election results and he
resigned a few weeks before the end of
the Trump Administration but then he was
asked if he'd vote for Trump over a
Democrat and he actually said yes that
the threat of Donald Trump is not
greater than the threat of a progressive
being put into power